[Music]
in privacy please news
so submitted by do you even lift bro oh
god yes I sometimes do [ __ ] hate
working out man if you can't tell you
know we know why it's just now man
beautiful you're on a good role for a
while I know but then my whole back I
can't break you my back car accident oh
I thought you were like breaking her
back and why now well I actually
breaking my back thanks guys I'm just
like exhaust once me to be [ __ ] fat
he's just sitting there just like just
trying too hard
you know how does lead cuz we had the
same I can't sleep problems not take
that back I worked out like two and a
half hours yesterday and I still
couldn't sleep
yeah you just bitched about that and all
I live I'd like to make it just grunting
as Deborah you know it's just like god
damn it I just want to have to take one
pill and I just start slowly losing
weight
hey most dumb people think that's
possible a man is suing a hospital after
they faxed his HIV positive status to
his workplace on accident it was an
accident I see that oh man that sucks
cuz you know what if he was trying to
get at one of the co-workers and he's
like you totally clocked bought me man
what the [ __ ]
mmm-hmm I think it's more about this
stigma of now you're that guy that has
what happened no HIV and you can if your
Magic Johnson you can be cleared of it
hmm neatly HIV free that's what money
was he yeah but I don't buy it ever I
thought I still getting medical
attention for my son now completely free
wait yeah what they cycle so much of
that new fresh blood into him because he
can so he can donate blood now cuz
that's all that's all I need to know
that's true I think so like he's clear
if you're a girl which got sex with him
without a condom no I think you should
have sex with him in general he's like
400 year old boy well he's very rich oh
that's different
rich dick is different molding Oh what
did he pay dudes have sex with them with
no
well he's a large man how much a million
dollar she'd take way less than a
million you need more than a million
dollars to clear the HIV though just
selection though a million dollars
barely get your housing do it if he
promises to pay for all the medical [ __ ]
yeah annual you test starbuck locations
what he owned them do he with a lot of
Starbuck on their way some franchises
I'll take that I'll do it
I'm not even a girl sex friends whatever
you plant transfusion chance anyway so
this man who is not being named
obviously right uh he's doing a New York
City Hospital for releasing his HIV
positives diagnosis you got the his new
his yeah to his workplace so initially
he said that he had asked them to mail
it mail his diagnosis to a burger box
no geo-buk and so the hospital obviously
completely ignored his request and faxed
it to his workplace where it faxed him
yeah they fax it and that's when one of
his co-workers saw the diagnosis and
then it was being passed around I would
sue that guy to ever pick up the fax
yeah look but if you're if you [ __ ] at
your workplace which a lot of people
[ __ ] where they eat let's be wrong like
you're fine like like if that happened
at the JK office you better believe in
[ __ ] knew passed around as we all
[ __ ] each other hey I'll just say the
truth once they're gonna edit it out but
don't let him do it we all [ __ ] each
other except the married one though the
comments are real especially the
marriage once you get married
the infidelity just does not stop dicks
and butts and [ __ ] in centipede
that's when you gotta get the [ __ ] out
of here bro you turn me into a terrible
person
no wonder America doesn't watch JK News
it's terrible you made me seem too
normal
yes so he's suing in the facility for
negligence and he's asking for 2.5
million dollars in damages really get in
trouble for stupidity though well they
the hospital did they did take
responsibility for for that whole
incident and she's got the hospital's
fault there should see the paper policy
though it was a Texan [ __ ] who [ __ ]
up and then the hospital gotta pay yep
yeah so the hospital did paid three
hundred eighty seven thousand dollars in
fines to the US Department of Health and
Human Services for violations under
HIPAA but this victim he says like he
his claims have been remained
unaddressed and so that's why he's suing
what about the person that made the
mistake how come it's always like the
big company has to deal with the
individuals mistake the part wasn't even
a mistake it was purview change and why
does the HIPAA money go to the
government when that cat's the one who
was injured yeah that doesn't make any
sense well it's that like body of
whatever law maintaining people that you
know I forgot the [ __ ] terminology
for it but they're they're there to
enforce the rules so I guess there's I
mean it's like the government finds
people for sure yes that's what they
were fine for but then the hall
monitor's yeah no but yeah so that's
what's happening but it was kind of that
that HIV positive diagnosis went all the
way into the hands of his own manager
and it led this victim to leave his
workplace because she was he says that
he was in a constant state of
apprehension and that the paranoia and
anxiety was too much for him to handle
well for sure I think that's reasonable
especially because like nobody want to
share a cup of them anymore and no [ __ ]
like that you know because people get
weird with that stuff your toilet some
people yeah
I can't you've never read a book in
their lives like I can't shirt while
with this man I can't shake hands a few
minutes I mean have you guys ever been
in to get an HIV test like I have I
think everyone yeah if they're an adult
and they have sex they should have all
STD tests and they should get tested for
HIV hepatitis all of that [ __ ] and what
I what I find weird is that they would
give him his results that way because I
remember when I was going to get the
test done they were like well if you get
a phone call from us we're gonna call
you to come back in you know that might
be something bad it's kind of like if
not if you get no calls you're like
you're cool but like if they call you to
come in to come into the office that's
when you got to worry because it's like
they don't want you to like commit
suicide like immediately because you're
just there alone they want to
face-to-face yeah and they didn't want
to talk to you and explain to you like
how to deal with men like some people
just don't know budget so I grow that I
was with she got text for uh sexual
transmitted diseases or whatever what at
the at the clinic and then she goes I
didn't get it in thing I was like cool
she goes you should check yourself too
I was like we have sex if I have I have
thank you no it's not a good thing to
promote and I'm not saying that I'm
saying like if you don't have it I don't
have it are you seeing science is bad
thing to promote yeah cuz the mean is
just talking science over here okay you
know I don't have it she goes she goes
but you should make sure I was like Oh
negative results it's the man's talking
about medical science I'm talking about
magic mumbo jumbo [ __ ] thank you getting
on my case about you I want you to get
like woman I had ready gotta check
before you so if you got check now that
means it's all it's already done I don't
we don't have any say oh my god folks at
home this is a great way to save money
with discount super we're gonna wrap her
head around it I was like you're dumb so
what we learned is have sex first and
then have someone else do the test Oh
God because I already responsible
I wasn't responsible because she didn't
get checked so I was a dummy but she's
got checked now you're the smart one you
know I got check before you before she
lights it for her so I was the dummy and
then she got check she goes you should
get checked them like you're lucky she
came back with nothing
yeah I kind of get sacked because when
you go to the clinic they don't have
lollipops like the dentist does that's
incredible I love it oh my god yeah what
would you guys demand from this hospital
in demand 3.5 million oh hey what that
was a number
this is 2.5 2.4 million because I have a
conscience yeah I think I want money and
I want the person who made the mistake
to humiliate themselves just so they
understand how it feels like to be
humiliated I want them to get HIV with
me maybe she is the one that got the HIV
from him she's like banging the nurse
you know he's banging the nurse and
she's always this [ __ ] got HIV
I'm saying this [ __ ] to his [ __ ] work
sitting into his house I'm saying what
does HIV stand for give human but it's
my it turns into a human
immunodeficiency virus Oh baby I was
closest its HIV and then it turns into a
yes what is age they have autoimmune
disorder yeah deficiency sent that means
your white blood cells don't work that's
why it's not AIDS that kills you it's
your ability to amass immune systems
when you get attacked elated by the
colds and flus of the world we got it we
got to figure out that cure for AIDS
already man they got it pretty good
really good and the conspiracy is it's
man-made that's what that's what people
say via the government's predators
yep that's the conspiracy yeah made it
like specifically to target certain
people like black people gays and blacks
yeah so there's no Asian people with
each other it's the lowest amount but we
get hepatitis I feel really
uncomfortable hepatitis and high blood
pressure for people's cholesterol all
the seafood it's always something else
do you guys try to get tested after
every partner because that's what you
should be done before after entering I
was younger I did not but now as an
adult I do before every partner they
should both at the same time yeah even
if you're gonna you know do it without a
condom yeah
even with I mean because you can still
get herpes and something else even with
a condom uh herpes is a myth you can get
herpes is in real you get herpes from
going to the dentist
yeah honey can get her on a different
way yeah herpes is just super common
remember it was like one out of three
people it was I don't know remember I
watched the video you guys said on
herpes sounds like malicious
misinformation but anything you get from
JK news you should always fact check it
because it's always always probably
always true absolutely exactly I use the
best form of evidence in science which
is anecdotal okay it's the best it's the
most accepted because we read half the
sentence and I'm pretty good yeah yeah I
go to WebMD and I know more than a
knocker and hearsay is always the best
way to get information anyway they've
been using it since the medieval times
I've actually been going to the OB for
the pregnancy stuff and we also keep her
vagina check yeah you know sometimes I
just gotta check it but I always asked
the doctor a lot of questions and he
tells me I don't know just google it
Namie he says it because like I guess
there's a lot of superstition stuffs and
things you can't eat can't do whatever
and I'll ask him about it but he's like
you know what nowadays Google will have
a better answer well you know it's funny
weed why the [ __ ] am I here pal what
have you overwhelmed him so much to the
point where it's like you know what just
Google it man I'm [ __ ] tired of you
asking so much that's how actually
probably what happened are you a
constant question guy well I ask
questions but I don't get anything so
you're asking questions all the time he
doesn't tell me [ __ ] so I just you know
I got this funder Civic right come on
man your doctor right hey you guys want
to stock any of us we'll go ahead down
to the description box below and you can
follow us on Instagram and all kinds of
stuff for more videos
[Music]
[Music]